regarde pas moi j'étais venu voir
strasse où je suis pas beaucoup dehors
alors moi je trouve mon et le petit
garçon bien une caravane passe contrôles
dans les rues de paris
alors le petit garçon qui venait avec
moi dans cette caravane est un petit
garçon lumeçon l'habitude 12e ou double
19e suis plus un ils disaient ouais ben
toi tu as une caravane et des trois
chansons on n'aurait pas eu jeudi si sûr
c'est vrai les pigeons squelettes des
gens comme nous
finalement si c'est sûr alors c'est lui
la star il a déjà fait pas combien de
pub il a tourné ne suis pas tombé de
cliff icaunais vous prenez les caméras
que moi en tout cas caméra team 5e
l'équipe
aline issermann que les serbes 2010
harrison voilà ça n'a jamais cessé et
qui n'ont jamais cessé c'est un genre à
part et à mon avis il est très difficile
de faire un bon clip
aujourd'hui où on a pratiquement tout
fait pour éviter que ça soit montage de
deux plans photos pour jeu pour fo il ya
quelqu'un qui je vais très bien je
trouve seulement dit nouri je trouve que
c'est très beau clip peut-être un jour
je serai peut-être je serai avec toi
non mais moi j'aime j'aime ce qui j'aime
ce que j'aime dans ça c'est surtout la
chanson la chanson parce qu'il chante ça
de rage mais quand francs est d'ailleurs
maintenue que là sur scène maintenant
ouais tu me fais tourner ton spectacle
tout non
fin des scribes le mans j'aime pas
beaucoup moins quand on quand on se fait
figurer sur scène parce que je trouve
que se voit une part dans un spectacle
c'est fait pour se voir comme ça en
direct et des choses après qu'ils
passent moins bien quand elles sont
filmées c'est un petit peu près le des
meetings pour les hommes politiques
le meeting cb ils peuvent être bons en
meeting est-ce qu'on voit après la
scission s'est passé c'est moins bon que
une interview télévisée
cette évidence est un objet quel
formidable mais qui peut être très
dangereux en ce qui concerne le direct
c'est une atmosphère de théâtre rigautou
raisin qui nous il ya des choses qu'on
fait en scène qui passe parce que
c'était d'un faible qui passe par un
départ était même métamorphose sera
filmé et enfin non je pense que ces deux
mêmes problèmes
moi je trouve que le théâtre passe très
mal à la télévision mais les extraits
souvent j'ai envie de voir une pièce
d'après je vois des excès à la
télévision et je me dis ah non c'est pas
beau ça
le plus beau c'est que je faisais
attention parce que ça ça passe pas
encore quand je le fais exprès on peut
arranger les lumières tout mais ça
manque ça manque de l'atmosphère c'est
pas la même chose
cinéma6 du cinéma télé c'est la télé le
théâtre solide théâtre faut pas mélanger
ce genre tu accueillant que je n'ai
connu récemment
enfin en tant que chanteur j'ai connu
une annonce je me souviens très bien que
j'ai entendu chanson à la radio des
tendances j'écoutais paye et c'était et
aux cayes à un souk al oui c'est ça
exactement
j'ai appelé gérard d'ailleurs pour
demander ce que c'était parce que j'ai
entendu deux fois et je voulais savoir
qui chantait savais pas qui c'était
je me souviens comment ça va frapper pas
parce que c'était très différent des
discours
tendent à cette époque en france c'est
très original surtout mais
malheureusement j'ai eu l'occasion de
les rencontrer très récemment ses
voisins oui alors vous travaillez là en
face de l'autre et vous allez vous avez
la même prof de chant concurrence pour
rendement que l led placées savoir l'un
des programmes charlot était est aussi
utile est aussi bénéfique pour les
chanteurs que pour les comédiens j'étais
me parler un peu plus de julien moi je
voudrais dire quand même ce coup de mou
moi j'aime j'aime beaucoup l'entendre
parce que parce qu'il a une voix et
parce qu'il chante et les moins en moins
de gens dans la chanson française chante
nord et à tous tous les trucs possibles
mais en ce qui concerne la musique c'est
souvent le braillements a été atténué un
peu par avant par des instruments d'une
station de blizzard et par des effets
lui adhérents des rares mais qu'encore
qui chante et sait chanter